anywhere you've worked have they tried  to put policies in place to get more  women yeah in the past I've um because  yeah in the film and security industry  they've tried to get women into more  um insecurity yeah in the film because  not represented enough you need to have  a certain amount of women women there  yeah  but it's not yeah yeah  I have a I have a friend like yeah yeah  mankind men can't search woman so  obviously women obviously like if it's a  scenario in a woman's toilet or  something like that you need you need to  have women's security yeah it doesn't  mean they're going to do the same thing  that men are going to do you'll be  surprised oh you're right to search okay